is there a scenario where empathy is
particularly difficult for you to
practice what you preach when people
come in with gobs of entitlement I'm so
triggered by my upbringing to be
anti-complaining to the extreme too far
my family took it too far but I'm giving
you a vulnerable honest answer I am most
challenged to deploy empathy when people
roll in with obnoxious entitlement is
definitely when I bite my inner cheek
but honestly back to like I'm so proud
of this this is kudos to Tamara and
Sasha vaynerchuk they did a really good
job I'm able to bite my inner cheek and
go into deep compassion sympathy and
empathy mode and go they might have been
brought up by parents that really
spoiled them or they might be over
correcting for the things that they're
upset with in society right now and
we're gonna fight the machine like I'm a
very happy man because I'm very quick to
not judge I think judging people is a
disaster I'm gonna put my feet in their
two shoes right this second and how did
I get to asking for some delusional ask
oh I know how I grew up in an
environment that didn't think that that
was a bad thing